to the emergencies act there are lots of
questions about what evidence the
government has to invoke it section 3
defines a national emergency as an
urgent and critical situation of a
temporary nature that seriously
threatens the ability of the government
of canada to preserve the sovereignty
security and territorial integrity of
canada and that cannot be effectively
dealt with under any other law of canada
there are checks and balances in place
in the act plus legal thresholds that
must be met those have yet to be spelled
out by the government david aiken is
looking at the legal and political
questions that need some answers david
well donna we have talked to several
experts over the last two days all of
who say there is considerable doubt as
to whether the government has legally
met the threshold to declare an
emergency
so the government is of canada
essentially having to say that these
protests
threaten the government's ability to
preserve the sovereignty security or
territorial integrity of canada which i
think is
quite a significant thing to be claiming
the emergencies act is not there
to
protect the canadian economy which is
one of the things that the government
has been talking about a lot and despite
press conferences yesterday and again
today with the prime minister and senior
cabinet ministers the government has yet
to provide details or explain why it
believes there is a national emergency
and exactly what it will do about it mr
speaker yesterday the prime minister
invoked the emergencies act
24 hours in and there are more questions
than answers i want to be very clear mr
speaker the scope of these measures are
time limited and geographically targeted
but does geographically targeted mean
they apply only to downtown ottawa or to
the entire city is it one border
crossing or all border crossings one
province or several the prime minister
did not say details like that and many
more are the kind of thing that both mps
and senators will want before they vote
to confirm the government's application
of the emergencies act by law both
chambers must begin debating this issue
within the week that debate will be
followed by a vote and the government
must get a majority in both chambers if
it fails in either chamber well that's
it that's the end of the emergency act
and the end of any special powers the
government wants to exercise donna
okay lots of steps still to come david
aiken in ottawa thanks